Jose is with me in Sacramento hi Jose
how are you I did I'm doing good how are
you doing better than I deserve what's
up hey awesome can you hear me okay sure
okay so right now I'm kind of wondering
what I should do at school
so right after high school I went
straight to a junior college and I was
really directionless I had no direction
I had no idea what I wanted to do
I finished my general ed pretty quickly
and it came about time to find out what
I wanted to major in so every time I met
up with an advisor I kind of felt a
little rushed and um school always kept
me busy and I always worked on the
weekends too so I didn't really have
time to think about what I wanted to do
so I changed my major a bunch of times
and somehow I leaned on history so I
ended up graduating the junior college
with an associates in history and
associates and behavior on social
sciences so I moved to the University
actually right down the street from my
house and now I'm going to school for a
bachelor's degree in history I don't
know what I want to do after and I'm a
little worried because I know people get
jobs in a degree that they people get a
job with a degree that had nothing to do
with and so I'm in high school my mom
actually took me to FPU and it was a
really good experience I was very very
thankful for it and so today I'm
actually on baby steps four five and six
and I'm just wondering like what my next
move is I feel kind of worried because I
don't know I feel like I'm not doing the
right thing right now I feel like maybe
there's something better out there for
me but I thought how old are you I'm 21
actually okay and would you finish your
history degree so this is a year and a
half but here's the thing so um no
exaggeration here but there's times in
school where I would read at least 80
pages a day and honestly I don't
remember anything that I read and I feel
like I could have used that time to
learn more about so for your Black
Friday so I actually bought a bunch of
your guys's books and I feel like I
could have used that time to like read
and learn more about stuff that I'm
interested in like investing in and
compound
interest and all that stuff and I feel
like going to school is just kind of
killing my time I know it's only three
semesters left but um I don't know if
I'm feeling impatient or not you know
and then yeah so well it's hard to be
excited about the trip when you don't
know what the destination is if I say
we're going to Florida to the beach you
can decide if you want to be excited or
not if I say we're going to the Rockies
to go skiing you can decide if you want
to be excited or not if I say we're
going fishing you can decide if you want
be excited or not you don't know where
the crud you're going there's no way to
be excited you feel like a rat in a
wheel because you're a rat in a wheel
yeah so we need if you need to figure
out what you're gonna do and then you
could say let's just make up something
okay I'm just gonna this is not what it
is
okay I'm not speaking this over you I'm
just making up a dream a weird thing
okay let's say you woke up and you said
I want to be a commercial real estate
agent and lease office buildings okay
let's just pretend you said that all
right now once you said that and you
said hey you know that's got finance in
it it's got compound interest it's got
investing in it it's got a lot of those
things in it I it's a real math nerdy
job commercial real estate agents or map
nerds the good ones are and you know if
you wanted to do that I'm just I'm not
saying that's it it probably isn't it
but once you say that then you can take
a stop and go all right do I want to go
ahead and knock this history thing out
because I'm pretty close or do I want to
go full stop and a hard right turn and
go get a finance degree and let's
investigate how far off the finance
degree we are off the history curriculum
and the history track how much of the
how much you know if I'm adding eight
years to this am i starting over no are
you adding four years no are you adding
a year I don't know but once you know
where your destination is then you can
determine okay it's not going to add
that much to change direction towards
something I actually care about what
you've you just went by the path of
least resistance
and I if you want to be a history writer
and you love history and you want to be
a history teacher you want to get a PhD
and become a professor of history
there's nothing wrong with that as a
career but then you have a you have a
solid track that you need to follow to
get there then
but right now you don't know where
you're going so there's no energy in it
hard to get the kids excited about
vacation when they don't know where
we're going and that that's what you've
got to work on you need to figure that
part out so if I were you what I would
do is it sounds like you may have banked
a little bit of money go to a a nice
place in Northern California that's not
that expensive for this weekend and
booked a hotel room by yourself where
there's some woods and water and beaches
or creeks or something and go walk
around and talk to God for the weekend
and take a blank yellow pad with you and
say okay what do I want to be when I'm
40 nobody stops and asked that instead
they get so busy busy busy busy busy
busy busy busy busy busy and look up and
go I'm just a rat in a wheel people
spend more time picking out a suit of
clothes and they do their careers so go
take a little time get quiet when it
gets quiet things get more clear we
don't take enough time to get quiet so
go somewhere where you can be around
nature that you like the mountain was
the beach I don't care what it is spend
a couple hundred bucks on a hotel this
weekend that's a super expensive
buy yourself a couple cheap hamburgers
and walk around and talk to God with a
blank yellow pad in your hand and then
go talk to some people in the field that
you think you heard you're supposed to
be in if it's commercial real estate
it's not but if it is go talk to
commercial real estate people when you
get home and ask them what it's like and
what they did you know what it's like to
get a CC
I am which is the designation for that
world and I want to go into financial
planning what's it like to get a CFP
because that's pretty rigorous a little
piece of training right there and so on
just go fit you know I want to be a
welder good I want to be a sculptor good
how's the history degree to fit into
that well it doesn't yeah but is it have
you got some base under you that you can
adjust and finish up with that degree
and get some core classes out as you go
out your senior year in the area you
want in I don't care if you get a
finance degree with 16 classes of I mean
a degree in history with 16 classes of
finance under your belt if you're going
into finance but your degrees in history
but while you were there you learned a
bunch about your trade that could be
your path I don't care but the problem
you've got is you don't have a
destination and you need a clear
destination intentionality is where
successful people come from they don't
always agree with them you don't always
like them it's never a straight path
sometimes it's a pile of garbage it's
ugly
sometimes it's icky there's all these
kinds of things come up but
intentionality doing crap on purpose
instead of just getting caught up in the
busyness of this world and that's what
changes everybody's life and you know I
thought I thought I was going to be a
commercial real estate agent by the way
I ended up buying properties and going
broke and residential properties
primarily I had some commercial and
actually God changed the direction
because I did one of what you're talking
about
I went and selling a Lake Bank put my
toes in the sand my butt in the chair as
Zach sings I said okay God what do you
want me to do because I'm really tired
of trying to figure this out by myself
and I started getting pretty clear
pretty quick after that